the first average check has gone up a
lot in the last 19 years what is the
pre-seed run what is the seed round
companies raising millions of dollars
right off the bat
but
how do you get to your first milestones
how do you build the company um i think
that uh
a lot of that has has has remained true
in the last decade
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opwest hello stanford leap and
birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders my guest
today is a good friend gilban alexey the
founding partner of upwest the only seed
fund that's purposely designed to help
israeli startups break into the us
market headquartered in silicon valley
and operating since 2012 opposed was the
first investor in sentinel 1 honeybook
and 80 other startups that raised over 2
billion dollars in follow-on funding
from top us vcs prior to upwest gill was
the vice president of operations
management at yahoo after working with
the company's corporate development
group
gil also served as a consultant advising
fortune 500 companies for the boston
consulting group in new york
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
for having me we're in the beautiful
offwest labs office as you can see it's
amazing new year but it's wonderful just
up west just up west wow okay that's it
so we're going to be talking about
changes we're going to be talking about
tonight the last nine years so let's
start from there nine years ago you and
shuli created this new idea israeli
entrepreneurs breaking into the u.s
market
things have evolved the israeli market
has changed we went from startup nation
we're now into scale-up nation how what
is it like from your end as the venture
capital investor
being there nine years watching this
israel ecosystem drive up yeah so first
of all it's been amazing uh we were
fortunate to start up west um actually
it's closer to 10. i can't believe it uh
close to 10 years ago uh so much has
changed back then you know israel still
had uh like he does today amazing
entrepreneurial spirit and power and
there was you know emerging landscape of
companies uh creating great momentum
fast forward 19 years
you know we all see what's happening you
have unicorns all over the place
companies raising just like in the us
raising it as well uh it's really been
we've seen a a a a huge shift an uptick
in on in companies that are creating
hopefully uh marquee brands
and um new emerging businesses
so right before we talk about you know
the the shifts but what also stayed the
same take me back almost 10 years take
me back to the to the founding idea and
how you and truly are you know
positioning yourself along with the rest
of the opposition
what does it mean you know to be in
venture capital you know in on the
israeli ecosystem what was the thesis
that you came in with yeah so so back
then we started with said look um same
same things we actually believe in today
which is
being in market increases your
likelihood to
build amazing businesses amazing
companies so back then um it's about
finding those entrepreneurs in israel
all the ones already in the us and
helping them with the first sort of few
years in their ecosystem so for example
we're fortunate to be in new york last
week um actually it was two weeks ago uh
on the sentinel one ipo that's the
company that we were the first investors
in 2013 and so just to use them as an
example um the first year or so they
were with us in our office space in palo
alto we were fortunate to help them find
the first investors and advisors and
customers and work with them um uh since
then and it's been just tremendous to
see how they were able to ipo the
largest ever cyber security company ever
we're excited about that we have a whole
slew of companies we believe that are
coming right up as well um so it's been
amazing to see that business that just
described in what we did with sentinel
one we believe still holds true today i
mean i know a lot has changed and is
changing post over it but the
fundamental belief that being in the
market can help you create the amazing
businesses we think still holds true
fast forward to today we also have a
staff and leah uh in israel
so we've grown a bit um but still we
love to do what we do
so what's happened you know from your
perspective over the last 10 years you
know we're seeing it all the time on the
news and there's a different vibe i
think going on in the streets here
especially in the area where we're at
what has happened to the israeli
ecosystem over the last nine years from
an objective perspective
so first of all globally we see the
numbers what has happened in israel is
amazing
we've actually seen similar things
around the world in the u.s as well um
i'm no expert but you know if you read
the last few days take a strike for
example they're talking about the ipo
north of 100 billion or so i don't know
i mean it's crazy you see snowflake
right uh the valuation airbnb so the uh
watermark i think has really gone up so
if in israel we used to speak about a
billion dollar company valuation uh now
it's like a tuesday right
now um uh thanks to
a tuesday right it's like uh but now you
have uh the likes of like i said 71 but
you see iron souls you see what
monday.com have done and a host of
amazing companies coming up though
they've raised the bar but i think the
ball the great news for israeli startups
and high-tech is that
you know you look up uh there's still
ways to go right and you can hear it in
the language of the founders that
they're aspiring for more which is
tremendous to hear so if you look at the
stripe and airbnb and and
and those guys we we can
we can get them right um we can build
those marquee companies what hasn't
changed uh is i think the mechanics of
building companies of building a company
of choosing the right investor and
starting off
is the same the first average check has
gone up a lot in the last 19 years what
is the pre-seed round what is the seed
round companies raising millions of
dollars right off the bat but how do you
get to your first milestone how do you
build the company um i think that uh
a lot of that has has has remained true
in the last decade right so what i'm
saying you know from friends and i'm
saying that there's a lot more confusion
because there's a lot there obviously
there's a lot more capital and and once
you're a hot deal or once you're once
you've proven that you are investable
then it's likely that not only one vc
would like to invest in you but now you
have a a few investors and sometimes
this can be blinding right and a lot you
talk a lot about choosing the right
first investors and the right first
partners with centum num1 you really
worked with them over the first year in
the offices and every time they come to
visit your office says i'm seeing
companies sitting there and there's no
office hours for giving children they're
just literally coming the office and
you're you're working with them day in
and day out
so what does it mean really to choose
to choose the right first investors the
right partners to run the journey for
maybe a you know an early stage company
that is just starting out that may be
getting blinded by what's happening now
so
you're right a lot has changed in the
sense that as a founder you have many
more fun financing options on average
than you did in the past you gave a few
examples here that if you get one-term
trading get more and maybe more money um
the excellent news
is that there's a lot of really good
investors in israel in the us everywhere
so for you as a founder just do your
homework right
spend time with the investors do your
due diligence on companies they invested
in and and and uh backed think about
what's the most important thing for you
uh now and in the future to succeed and
pick the one that if you fortunate to
pick just pick the one that fits you the
best um maybe eight ten years ago you
didn't have that luxury now you do uh so
i think that's uh that's been key i
think for us what we've tried to do as a
fund is also grow with the time so if in
the past uh our check size was mostly
focused on pre-seed a few hundred
thousand dollars fast forward to today
we're writing checks of a few hundreds
of thousands to a couple of million
dollars so we look to co-lead or lead
pre-seed and seed round of let's say up
to four or five million dollar round so
for us we've tried to grow a little bit
with our check sites but still be the
first check just like in 701 just like
in all of our 80 plus portfolio
companies across so many domains being
that first check or almost the first
check is what we aspire to do and go and
help the companies as as they begin to
grow in the u.s market
is there a difference in the perspective
or the mindset of the entrepreneur from
that first investment until their next
round are there different you know
timeline expectations and you know the
different growth trajectories that
they're that they're feeling pressured
to to do because they have to raise this
around pretty soon or anything of that
sort
2021 is slightly crazy here i don't
think i'm breaking any news here right
but but right now sitting in this office
in july
it can get pretty wild certain domains
certain companies um you see them uh
gain momentum a few months after the
the financing round and then they get
knocked you know knocks on the door from
the next one of investors saying you
know take my money now why wait another
six 12 months so it can be a little bit
confusing which i think um
which i think can distort things but
under the each case of the case-by-case
basis under the right situation maybe
you want to spay yourself the the
trouble of going through the financing
but sometimes like i said before you
want to do your due diligence on on
investors and the right time to raise
the next round um it can get very
confusing um you know people come into
you with lots of money um
which is hopefully um why why
founders i i see much more today in the
past talk to one another and learn from
one another and see what steps they've
taken on what was correct and what was
incorrect in hindsight uh especially in
israel which is such a collaborative
ecosystem which is obviously fantastic
to see
and so it's early stage investors what
is really the the push that you give the
entrepreneurs you know today or before
as as you're working in the 80 plus
portfolio companies
what what does the partnership tangibly
look like yeah
so
the way we think about it and the way we
tell our fans to think about it is
it's to think about it as a partnership
and it's a long long journey sometimes
you open the press and you're like wow
these companies they it seems like they
move so fast and there is so much money
central one was eight and a half years
we have companies we've invested nine
years ago that nine ten years ago are
still growing strong so we want to be
there for the long term and that's what
we want the founders to see us at
for us it means in the early days
anything from um finding the first set
of employees to finding the next round
of investors uh to finding the first set
of customers um for us
as a fund our focus is really the u.s
market so it's getting those customers
that can afterwards serve as amazing
reference points for the future some of
the early customers of again going back
to central awards were netflix and box
that really helped propel them going
forward because it positioned them as
sort of this you know u.s based company
with with customers that could be super
referenceable for the next fortune 500
companies that that come after so for us
it's early employees fall off investors
um
customers and
frankly a lot of things that go on in
the early stage of startups that um
you know you you sometimes don't talk
about right so how do you get the right
management team on board how do you get
you know all the founders on the on on
the right page so for us it's really
about uh
being there for the founders in those
early years and supporting them
throughout the process
and is that you know something that the
founder can prepare for you know ahead
of time understanding you know all this
diligence is that is it really do you
think domain specific is it more on a
personal level figuring out what
investors you want to personally
interact with because when you're just
brought into the conversation is this
idea that you're actually not looking
just for somebody who's very well
connected and can push you forward but
somebody that can help you resolve
conflicts internally and think
critically how do you grow the right
management team right
exactly and and again there's there's
lots of really good investors out there
and you want to find the ones that can
help mentor you and guide you throughout
the process you get to choose your
partner in a way right who sits on your
board and and and and will be there for
the long term hopefully um
so yeah it's uh it's definitely
interesting times
so where are we moving from here
it's a great question i think
a lot of things are still being figured
out right everybody is talking about
so in the postcode world in theory by
post-variant world uh what's gonna
happen are people going to go back to
the office uh the way it was i think we
could probably
pretty safely say no it's not gonna be
exactly the same but what's the middle
ground some companies are trying to push
you can see in the u.s and israel junk
push for everyone to come back for
almost all the time
they're getting resistant from that so
that's one question that's out there
i personally believe things are going
are never going to go back to the way
they were but we'll be in a good middle
ground and i think each company has to
decide what's their dna
some companies are going like you know
we just okay with people working
remotely 100 percent
some companies are going to push to
mostly come to the office
but
that milk ground i think is going to be
the hardest to navigate so that's one
question the second question is is you
know the money it seems to be flowing on
the streets how long can this last i you
know i studied economics and undergrad i
wasn't very good at it but i do remember
the cyclicality of
of the economy right uh and so now we're
on a high i don't know how to say it but
probably there's going to be a low at
some point um when well anybody's
guessing interest rates are low so we'll
see what happens it doesn't seem to be
anything in in the very near future but
who knows
so that those are so the two main
questions but at the same time for us as
sort of early stage investors we are
still
laser focused on on those founders that
really are trying to solve a major
problem yes there's all these
distractions that are happening but the
lazy focused on the problem they're
super passionate about they really want
to focus on and they want to dedicate
the next few years plus of their lives
on it uh and that's what inspires us to
do what we do right we get our energy
from them right um so uh that that's
really been uh uh uh what the great joy
of this business and so really what's
your kick out of all this so what you
know you come you wake up every day
you've mentioned you're moving back and
forth three months to california three
months three months but it's crazy it's
a crazy life that you're leaving you're
working with more than 80 companies
every day you're seeing new companies
you're you're looking at new verticals
it's very tiring i'm sure it's very
confusing but what's really the joy that
you're getting out of out of you know
working without quest or invent venture
capital in general yeah um look first of
all up west is a startup on its own
right so 10 years ago we started up west
we grew it a little bit we're growing it
a little bit now but we're still
remaining i think small and nimble and
as a startup you know we have a set of
customers our founders that we work with
and what we get the greatest joy is
helping them work through their own
vision and their own uh uh set of
beliefs um you know
personally i get great joy of working
with various domains and various
founders um and and being there for them
they're the heroes in
in in this crazy uh of you know mini
world we live in in sort so the high
tech and you know two weeks ago was a
great reminder of that through selling
the important milestones for the company
but
um sometimes it doesn't end that way
sometimes uh it goes to an m a or or
sometimes the company doesn't work out
it's it's it's being there for the
not just for the highs that's easy it's
being there for the lows and i think
that's where we um try to work with the
founders to see what makes the most
sense uh but that the highs the lows um
anything um it's uh it's just for us
just working with the people and the
founders that makes the most difference
for us and the guys that nowadays the
same i'm sorry i guess that no day is
the same not at all uh not at all but
but it's great i mean you know my uh
other universities that i know they they
feel the same thing it's it's it's that
the
excitement that we see um
that that really is
is is tremendous in the world that we do
i want to take you back to your
childhood and i have a few last
questions that i ask everybody now i
didn't prepare you in a glance so i'm
warning you already
take me back to your childhood you know
middle school
what really fascinates you as a kid you
know what you know you want you walk
life you walk through the streets what
really occupies you
and you know as a kid
um
what really occupied me as a kid um a
few things um
uh on on the super personal life i love
sports so uh that that's one
second my uh uh commodore 64 with tape i
think uh occupied me for a while uh i
was dumbfounded when the floppy disk
came i was like what what a miracle
um but then you know after that it's
it's you know everybody reads books and
the books i gravitate toward that i
don't know it was all about
autobiographies like the world's
greatest companies you know uh
whether it's from the mcdonald's of the
world to the apple story of the 80s
night of the 80s 90s um
those were tremendous and i think it got
me thinking a lot about what it takes to
build this uh global brands and global
companies um i've never lived in the
states before um going there 20
plus years ago that's a long time ago
but that's why i made the move i thought
that being there that ecosystem um
probably in my lifetime
possibly would be the best place to try
to build those companies at and so
that's what got me going initially to go
to business school there and and and try
to help so israelis that try to follow
suit and build their companies that way
both as a kid and as an economic
undergraduate did you think that you're
going to be working in in the
intersection of finance and innovation
was this always sort of the the
convergence of gil absolutely not
so
when i came to the us i always thought i
would be in corporate
i would love it um and it worked well
from for several years i i joined yahoo
corporate development and grew in the
organization
but um
just just being in the valley and seeing
lots of israeli founders come through
the valley and seeing their struggles
and the challenges they faced um
you know from 2005 to 2010 and onwards
um i think that once you hear the same
story again and again they think
inspired shulie and i to sort of uh kick
start up west and and do that and i
think once we got the taste of the
startup that is up west uh we never look
back uh that this is sort of our startup
but uh and and in a way our mission but
that's
what sort of got me sidetracked from
this uh
very uh good corporate life i sometimes
ask myself i could have had i think and
i'm like wow that would have been fun
being in some company but here we are uh
at the super early stage of startups and
obviously i have zero regrets and and
and only very grateful that i uh
uh stumbled upon it many years ago now
i've already answered the second
question about what inspires you today
and you mentioned the work with the
founders the customers of upwest and how
you're thinking through partnering with
them in the long run but the last
question and the trickiest one three
words
two four five however many times that
you would use to describe yourself or if
i would ask surely who who is gil yeah
uh
so first of all hopefully being an
advisor so advisory role to the startup
is something that i aspire to do
second i'm i'm i try to be trustworthy
and i work in it and and really so found
this field that can be super open with
me and with us
and third it's not one word it's sort of
two but it's hyphenated which is called
saba which is the city i grew up in and
uh my parents my family many many
cousins all live there so those are
probably some of the three words i would
use to describe myself
thank you very much thank you